moi je vais parler de Samantha Samantha
un peu plus elle est blonde elle en peut
plus fait franchement j'ai un peu plus
que tout le monde me prend pour une
conne je te jure j'en peux plus je vais
me tendre en brune tu vois elle sent en
brume elle est contente [ __ ] c'est bon
quoi ça va aller je vais je vais enfin
kiffer la live de ouf tu vois et puis se
balade dans la campagne tu vois elle est
dans la campagne comme ça et puis il y a
un champ avec plein de plein de brebis
tu vois plein plein j'adore les brebis
je te jure c'est mon kiff de ouf comment
j'aimerais trop une vraie vie je te jure
et puis après le le mec là qui est le tu
vois les pièces excusez-moi monsieur
excusez-moi j'aimerais être une brebis
on peut faire un geste s'il vous plaît
pour moi qu'est-ce que tu veux faire bah
si c'est le nombre de brebis que vous
avez j'en prends une quoi tu vois ouais
ok vas-y ah vous en avez à 2147
comment tu sais ça toi je sais pas si
c'est sorti comme ça d'un coup
je kiffe trop les brevis c'est trop mon
kiffe tu vois
on peut faire on peut faire un jeu tous
les deux bah ouais je sais pas c'est une
bonne idée mais vas-y hein si je
découvre ta couleur de cheveux tu as
vraie couleur de cheveux je reprends ma
brebis
c'est peut-être pas une bonne idée mais
vas-y je pense que tu es blonde ah ouais
mais comment tu sais parce que là tu as
pris mon chien
donc ouais c'est deux blondes qui sont
devant la Tour Eiffel elles sont comme
ça
un truc de ouf
s'il y a pas d'ascenseur on est obligé
de monter à pied c'est un truc de ouf
moi et donc
c'est génial c'est un truc de ouf il y a
un mec qui arrive excuse mais du speak
English ah non Speak Now in English non
surtout pas quand tu vas
pas parler italien
Panzani ça va quoi
ah non pas de German non non pas Duche
rien du tout jamais de douche le matin
le soir jamais OK
espagnols
à côté faire ça serait peut-être pas mal
qu'on apprenne quand même à parler des
langues étrangères ah ben tu vois lui il
en parle 4 ça ne sert à rien du tout
c'est de potes qui parlent tous les deux
comme ça ils sont tous les deux et puis
il dit à l'autre c'est bien tu as laissé
les blondes de côté
je peux la faire revenir après dans
l'histoire on va voir alors c'est un
pote et une blonde qui parle
[Rires]
un truc super
merci à côté ils ont fait un truc
extraordinaire au lieu de payer 30-40
balles je suis ton dentiste il y a une
espèce d'ordinateur tu mets tes urines
dedans il te dit exactement ce que c'est
que tu vois ok le mec est un peu
sceptique
tu viens de Samantha il y a aucun
problème tu as vu l'impôt
il pisse dans le truc il arrive à la
pharmacie ils vont un espèce
d'ordinateur comme ça
donc il met son aimer son urine ils vont
et puis c'est 10 balles [ __ ] ça c'est
pas cher mais le petit billet tu vois 10
balles
[Musique]
[Rires]
vous avez une tendinite au coude
évitez de les charges lourdes et mettez
votre coude dans l'eau chaude très
régulièrement [ __ ] génial truc de fou
tu vois et le mec il est un peu con il
dit waouh ça te fous ça alors attends
j'aimerais bien faire une connerie avec
leur dit la machine j'ai rien tenter un
truc tu vois donc il rentre chez lui tu
vois il est un peu un peu marvalo le
gars qu'est-ce qu'il fait il prend le
petit la petite fiole il dit attends je
vais retourner on va faire une blague
mets un petit peu d'eau de chez lui tu
vois un petit peu d'eau du robinet et il
promène son chien comme ça il sait un
temps j'ai fait un truc tac il prend la
merde de son chien hop il met un petit
peu dedans et tout
Yassine t'as pas envie de pisser par
hasard ouais monsieur ouais tiens vas-y
même un petit peu de pissouille c'est
pour un copain machin il met un petit
peu la pistouille de sa femme mitoyas il
fait pareil que sa fille ouais chérie un
petit peu la puissance un petit peu la
pissage
comme dernier truc à la con comme ça
il va dans les chiottes
il se paluchent
et tout Yass son mari dédicace
je vais [ __ ] la machine c'est
obligatoire il va la machine il met sa
petite fiole il met le petit billet de
10 balles tu te fous
et tu sors il est là je préfère le lire
parce que j'ai pas retenu et le ticket
sort il lit ton nom est dégueulasse
achète un filtre à eau ton chien a des
verres achète lui des vitamines la fille
se drogue à la cocaïne mais là dans un
centre de réhabilitation ta femme est
enceinte de jumeaux ils sont pas toi
prends un bon avocat
et si tu arrêtes pas de te branler ton
cou ne va jamais guérir
c'est un patron de bar il est dans son
bar tranquille et il y a un mec qui
rentre voilà et les mec qui rentre comme
ça et il dit moi je voudrais un whisky
et je paye pas parce que j'ai peur de
personne
un peu petit et tout comme ça le mec est
grand et tout fais chier [ __ ] bon
allez vas-y c'est qu'un whisky je sors
son whisky l'autre il boit son whisky il
se barre son pays oh [ __ ] lendemain
rebelote le métier là et ouais moi je
voudrais le whisky je paye pas parce que
j'ai peur de personne [ __ ] fais chier
le mec il est super emmerdé parce qu'il
est quand même balèze et tout je sers
son verre de whisky mais je tiens c'est
la dernière fois que tu m'as [ __ ]
celui-là je te jure donc il bat il boit
le verre de whisky le mec se barre il
appelle un petit attends j'ai un mec qui
me fait chier tous les jours ça fait
deux fois qu'il vient déjà euh il a
peut-être son pote le plus balèze qui
existe le plus balaise un mec de mettre
125 kg une masse vas-y viens Jojo tu
t'attends le mec troisième jour Jojo il
est là au bar
le mec arrive moi je veux un verre de
whisky je paye pas parce que j'ai peur
de personne là Jojo il se retourne fait
moi non plus j'ai peur de personne
alors deux whisky
une petite dernière pour la fin c'est un
journaliste de TF1 qui veut faire un
petit reportage encore ça à l'époque de
Jean-Pierre Pernaut lui fait un gros
bisou et donc et donc le mec va encore
dans un tout petit village entre la mer
et la montagne magnifique et rencontre
un vieux un vieux un vieux maire tu vois
le mec 95 ans tu vois et voilà et donc
il a le reportage il me suit il
s'appelle aussi monsieur Rossi on va
faire un petit reportage sur vous ça va
être magnifique on va mettre en valeur
votre village et tout donc je vais vous
poser des questions allez-y on y va les
gars c'est parti allez première question
monsieur Rossi en tant que maire de
votre petit village en Corse quel est
votre meilleur souvenir
mon meilleur souvenir j'avais une
biquette
bon et alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé
alors rechercher partout la biquette on
va chercher dans les petites rues
chercher à Fontaine chercher partout on
trouvait pas la biquette et ah bon et
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé un jour
on a retrouvé la biquette elle était
perdue dans le boss et alors qu'est-ce
que vous avez fait on a fait la fête à
la petite fontaine
tout le monde était pété ah d'accord et
alors qu'est-ce qui s'est passé alors on
a pris la biquette et on a [ __ ] la
biquette comme ça
arrêtez non excusez-moi les gros refait
non non non on refait on refait les gars
bon là on l'a refait monsieur aussi
monsieur Rossi en tant que mère de votre
petit village encore ce qu'elle est quel
est votre plus votre meilleur souvenir
voilà et votre meilleur souvenir
[Rires]
on trouvait pas le bœuf ah d'accord et
alors un jour on a retrouvé le bœuf il
était perdu dans le basket
qu'est-ce que vous avez fait la facture
alors on a pris le bœuf et on a [ __ ] le
bœuf
c'est moi c'est de ma faute je pose les
mauvaises questions alors en fait c'est
bon tac c'est parti monsieur Rossi en
tant que mère de votre petit village
encore quel est votre plus mauvais
souvenir le plus mauvais souvenir
c'est quand je me suis perdu dans le
boss
[Applaudissements]